y una oración para encomendar sus vidas
a dios de esta manera fueron despedidos
decenas de integrantes de la reserva del
ejército y voluntarios armenios su
misión es la de alcanzar la frontera en
la región de nagorno karabakh para
sumarse a las filas de las fuerzas
armadas armenias que luchan contra el
ejército de azerbayán
como después de la llamada de la oficina
alistamiento militar en seis minutos ya
estaba allí y ahora estoy aquí yendo a
defender mi patria todos nos reunimos
para defender a nuestro santo nuestro
arte nuestra armenia pero desde la otan
y eeuu hasta rusia eran son varios los
países que instan a ambas partes a
establecer un alto al fuego sin embargo
turquía se muestra como una voz
discordante dentro de la comunidad
internacional este país aliado de
azerbaiyán acusa a las fuerzas armenias
de ocupar territorio azerí y mantiene
que no habrá un cese al fuego antes de
una retirada armenia
jermaine están la observación poner a
armenia y azerbayán en igualdad
significa otorgar derechos a los
ocupantes
we hill que el mundo debe estar del lado
de los que tienen razón es decir del
lado de azerbaiyán a jackson en jean y
azerbaiyán en anda jr al norte
mientras tanto en la capital armenia la
propaganda se organiza pruebas que se
alistan para un conflicto que no esperan
que termine de un día para otro
[Música]